Well in a very large part thanks to oversimplified,
we did it.
We reached 50k subs.
Thank you everyone so much for subscribing
and giving my channel a try.
To celebrate I have made this extra video
for all of you so you can laugh at me.
Because this video is all about mistakes I
have made in my videos.
After all I am human, I think, and I make
mistakes as everyone else and even though
I try my best to catch these mistakes some
are bound to slip through and make it in to
the final product.
With that said I would like to say that when
I do catch a mistake or one is pointed out
to me by you guys I always put a correction
in the description.
So it’s good practice to check that before
you write yet another comment about a mistake
I already know about and have mentioned in
the description.
Without further adieu, let's begin.
The first few videos I made where more of
just Wikipedia narrations so there isn’t
much I could have gotten specifically wrong
in them.
But I did oversimplify certain things to such
a point that you could call it being wrong.
For example in my Bratislava video I just
have a graphic saying that Bohemia, Austria
and Hungary interchanged control of Bratislava
a bunch during an unspecified period.
This is in the simplest of terms true, but
I don’t give a date when these exchanges
of control happened or how often they happened
or even in what order they happened.
So you can see how it can be counted as a
mistake.
But such oversimplifications I am not going
to put in to this video because there’s
a lot of them in my early videos, since I
wasn’t really sure back then what I was
doing.
However, I will mention one thing which isn’t
really a mistake but bothers me to this day.
In the video about Edinburgh, here I meant
to say “No that’s George”, but you know,
a spelling error made it Gerge whatever that
means.
My fourth video about Reykjavik has a lot
of mistakes but I already addressed that in
my History of Iceland series so I won't mention
it here, just know it’s not a good video.
The only reason I keep it up is because I
want people to see that I am actually making
an effort in improving production and research
of my videos and I didn’t just start off
making good videos, on the contrary the early
videos where pretty bad.
Now my History of Hockey video had a pretty
bad mistake, I said Hurly was a British sport.
Which if you know anything about hurly and
it’s fans meant that I got a bunch of angry
comments.
Now in my defence I meant that hurly was a
Brithonic and Irish sport as it evolved from
an earlier celtic game played on the British
isles.
But I made the unfortunate mistake of thinking
British and Brithonic was the same thing,
which it is not.
Hence the mistake.
Another stupid mistake was math related in
my only none History video on the channel.
I averaged numbers of three different costs
depending on the type of university without
taking to account that the student population
in the US isn’t evenly distributed between
public and private universities and of instate
and out of state students.
Even though I treated them as such.
That was dumb on my part, I am not good at
math and there’s a reason I stayed with
just history for this channel after that.
Ahh my slavic video.
Many people got angry about this one.
It doesn’t really have a mistake per say
as I am just stating theories and there isn’t
enough evidence to definitively support any
of them.
But I am putting it here as a mistake because
I just didn’t explain well what I was trying
to say in the video, which is my fault.
No one is arguing that the slavs when they
emerged on the political stage during the
migration period didn’t come from somewhere
north of the Dniestr and west of Dnieper.
They definitely did, what I was trying to
talk about is when and from where did the
slavs come from in to that area, they couldn't
have been there for all eternity.
Where they there since the 5th century BCE
or did they come there in the 3rd century
CE, or any other date, did they come from
the north or the East, did they already split
with the Balts or not, etc. we just don’t
know, hence all the different theories I talked
about in the video.
Next is my Western Slavic History video.
And no this one doesn’t have any mistakes
you boneheaded nationalists are thinking of.
It infact has a pretty dumb mistake.
I call the first ruling dynasty of poland
the Mieszko dynasty which it is not it’s
the PIast dynasty, Miezsko is just the first
none disputed king of the Piast dynasty.
Quick mistake in the Blue Blood video I called
Hispania hispaniola which it obviously isn’t
as hispaniola is an island in the carribean,
but in my defence they’re pretty similar
names.
The next one is again technically not a mistake
but I think it’s worth talking about.
It refers to my use of the red cross on a
white background to represent Columbus’s
ships.
No one actually really knows what symbol,
if any, Columbus had on his sails, specially
during the first voyage.
However almost all depictions of the voyages
show the ships having a red cross on a white
background.
This would be very possible as two of the
three ships were caravels which are of Portuguese
origin who used the red Knights Templar cross.
(origins of this cross comes from the crusade
same as the English cross hence the similarity)
Plus to add to this Genoa where Columbus was
from also had a main symbol of a red cross.
On top of that the Spanish have been known
to use the red cross on a white background
as well although for them it was suppose to
symbolize the Cross of Saint James which depending
on how drawn can look very similarly to the
Templar’s cross.
All this means that it is very likely that
Columbus had a red cross on a white background
on his ships but again we just don't know
for sure.
Next is New York city history video.
This mistakes a good one.
I pointed to 500 Fifth Avenue building and
called it the Rockefeller center and noone
noticed for like a week before a bunch of
New Yorkers started typing I am a moron.
So, yeah, made a mistake there.
Another mistake is in my Eastern Slavic history
video where I say the Scandinavians acquired
the knowledge of making damascus steel from
India through the eastern european waterways
so they could create their famous ulfberht
swords.
Well for one knowledge of creating damascus
steel comes from the middle east not India
and the vikings never actually made damascus
steel.
as the ulfberht swords never actually were
true damascus.
They were sometimes considered as pattern
welded "false Damascus" steel which is a form
of crucible steel but isn't actually true
Damascus steel.
So what I meant to say is that the Vikings
acquired knowledge to create crucible steel
through the Eastern European waterways which
unlike damascus steel does originated from
india.
The last mistake I’ll point out is in the
Mexican War of Independence video where I
show a picture of Prince Pedro announcing
Brazilian independence and claim it to be
the Spanish liberal revolution, right after
that I show a picture of the Portugese government
claiming it to be the Spanish liberal government.
But let’s be honest, to a laiman this doesn’t
matter, the pictures are there to serve a
narrative purpose not to be actually part
of the History I am talking about.
So to all I don’t know 50 of you that pointed
out the mistake, I know it is a mistake, but
it’s not that big of a deal as you claim
it to be.
That’s where I will end this video thank
you all so much for 50 thousand subscribers
and here’s to another 50 thousand.
Ou and I have a Patreon you can check out.
See you next time.